the protest was held exactly one year
before brazil's presidential elections
tens of thousands of brazilians from all
walks of life took to the streets of rio
de janeiro and 19 other state capitals
they may disagree on who should govern
latin america's largest economy but they
say they know who should not
the protesters danced to the same drum
beat to demand president bolsonaro's
impeachment
he is destroying the environment the
economy the democratic institutions this
government is squeezing the air out of
the people
protests against jair bolsonaro began
since he publicly denied the kovit 19
pandemic which has killed almost 600 000
brazilians to date
but now a growing number of left-wing
political parties have joined forces
with trade unions and social
organizations
even if they don't see eye-to-eye they
have a common goal
brazil is politically polarized polls
show 46 percent of the population
supporting former president luis
signiasso lula da silva from the leftist
workers party and 25 percent in favor of
bolsonaro
that leaves 30 percent of brazilians
still looking for a candidate from the
center
but polls also indicate that 59 percent
of brazilians reject bolsonaro
an impeachment is unlikely to happen
because although there are enough
reasons to force bolsonaro out he still
has support in congress but it's
important to show the country that the
majority of brazilians want him out
and these protesters say
that can only be achieved by making
their voices heard out on the streets
manuka yanakiv al-jazeera
[Music]